Great. You're listening to radio,
the podcast from New York public radio and public radio.
W. Y. C
n p. R.
[inaudible].
Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad, and I'm busy listening to this. Who is it?
I'm Robert Krulwich. This is Radiolab. The podcast. Yeah.
Yes, please.
So this person that you're hearing right now, testing, testing,
she's one of my favorite, favorite musicians. You introduce yourself.
My name is, I am a, my name's Juana Molina.
I'm quantum Medina and I am a musician.
I hope you enjoy what I do. Okay.
So you know sometimes on this podcast instead of the science and the big ideas
and the whatever we present musicians. Yup.
Well that's what I want to do for the next 10 or so minutes.
Mostly cause I think she's amazing,
but also because when we used for music in the sperm show,
I use it for some of the breaks. This song right here, in fact,
we get [inaudible] flood of email. People asking about,
I wonder what she thought about being the breaks in the sperm show. She didn't.
She doesn't know.
So this podcast is for the bunch and bunch and bunch of people who wrote in
asking about Juana Molina and also for the rest of you who maybe don't know her
yet,
but we'll hear her now and maybe I hope fall in love with her music as I have.
Yeah.
[inaudible]
so let me make space here. Okay.
So I spoke with her recently as she was in town to play a Gig at this club
called the plots zone rouge request or who's the [inaudible] fish? Yup.
And she told me her backstory, it's to interesting,
you started out as a musician taking piano lessons and guitar lessons,
trying to be a performer. It wasn't really working out at that point.
So she needed a job and she wasn't really sure what to do,
but she knew she was always good at impressions. Something I could always do.
And it was easy for me just to impersonate characters. And then,
and you believe newer people like main stereotypes
or are [inaudible]
I dunno if it's stereotypes or architects. Both. I mean, yeah.
Oh, that's interesting. Yeah.
And then one day was this parade looking for a job that gave me
enough money to play music and I thought TV was the best option. You,
you went to TV to help pay for music.
So what she did was she went over to the local TV station,
somehow convinced them to give her a job reporting fake news,
sort of like the daily show. And eventually she got her own show called
Juana Isuzu [inaudible].
Okay.
Which means Juana and her sisters. It was sort of a comedy show.
It was just a sketches. Yes. And how long did that go for? Three years.
For the beginning it works very well because I had money and he could pay my
rent and my guitar lessons. But then I got big. She became a huge hit.
Was that the kind of situation where you'd walk down the street and be
recognized? Yeah, much to her dismay. Oddly suddenly she was an actress,
not a musician. And as she puts it, her life Kinda got out of hand.
Well a, but then she got pregnant, I got pregnant and I needed to stay in bed.
Um, so I had time to,
to think about my life on the realize that I had totally missed my goal.
It was just that I didn't want to miss it.
I didn't want a dad and not having done what I wanted to do.
So at the height of her popularity as an actress, she drops out. Yeah.
That's not what I wanted. They just want it to be a musician.
So she starts playing in these little clubs, just her and her guitar.
People respond badly, didn't go so well.
I'm going to try out a third and a fourth and fifth and some all in the way.
And this is what I love. As you're listening, you slip into this universe.
Absolutely nothing that I really want to say really. I mean,
you have lyrics sometimes, most of the times.
So when the song pops into your head and you develop it,
you're not thinking of a story per se. No. Never.
But you put the story on afterwards. Why in order to be able to sing? Yeah.
One day, one day, one day, one day when dia,
uh, how did that, how did that happen? Was what? I'm going up for the show.
And I started to, I got bored and I started to play
[inaudible] and it sounded like one day he wasn't saying one day,
but it sounded like you didn't have the words just yet to know.
But then when I was singing, Eh,
[inaudible]
game up on the [inaudible], the one day it will be someone.
And Amazingly, her manager wrote me back and he said, totally,
you can remix it. Really? So I remixed the song. Oh my God. It was,
was this guy, you know, was this going to bonus IRA? So was, where was he? No,
it turns out he's just down the street. He was in New York.
Can we hear your vision? Yeah. How can I do that?
Hold on.
Okay, I've got it right here. Okay. So here it is.
Here's the short excerpt from a remix that her manager was nice enough to let me
do of, of her song of Juana Molina Song when Dia
[inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] hmm.
okay. I want to thank Paul Dalan and Juana Molina.
You can also go to Juan molina.com check out her music and I want to thank
Michael Raphael for some of the sounds used in that remix as well as Stewart
Dempsey for some of the music and the corporation for public broadcasting,
the Sloan Foundation and the National Science Foundation for helping to make
radio lab possible. I'm jab boom Rod, and I'm Robert Krulwich.
We'll catch you in two weeks.